[Music]
please don't get involved
what is poppin thickies it is monday
morning at 10 a.m
coming to you live
not live but you know what i'm saying
i'm in your screen right now maybe you
watch
a little cell phone maybe watch this at
work and you're positive when your boss
walks by
because he's familiar with my voice and
he knows you're not working if my voice
is popping
uh fresh off
the car ride from san diego san diego in
san diego it's it's uh
san diego one of my very favorite places
to perform my first special ever was
there at spreckels theater um this time
i'm usually at la jolla
but um
we
did a little uh
remix and uh did the new laugh factory
in san diego and the gaslight district
downtown san diego phenomenal room great
freaking club great weekend
um i just so happen to be there the same
time as comic con
so you're getting a lot of
listen i'm not familiar with comic-con
but um
i assumed it was like young kids and
college kids new doo doo this is
grown men dressed up as star wars and
pokemon and
oh you name it dustil dawn characters
and walking dead there's some guys at
t-rex we saw two guys uh dressed i
thought it was the
was those guys daft punk remember the
daffodils helmets i thought was that but
they're from star wars and a silver bmw
it was
bananas down there i mean it was i
listen
the pandemic obviously things are open
up people aren't locked down
you know san diego never really locked
down teach their own but um
most of that go into on tour still
aren't fully like 100 back you know like
not
that energy has never since pandemic
none of the energy has matched you know
since pre pandemic
san diego was different
i'm i walked around like i mean just
packed dude you were down there chad
yeah it was chaos yeah like i would get
out of the lab factory like you know i
don't know 12 31 you're walking like
holy [ __ ] yeah i mean
packed not too much i think
it was a little yeah i like it just
because it you know it's the one there's
the one city since the pandemic that
felt
fully fully normal not only normal but
even more
kind of lively yeah
you know which is you know for better or
worse but um
the same energy was in the shows man
every show was a rocking daddy
and we'll have a green room diary
uh
bit for you uh probably tomorrow this
one uh is so long it's about the
homeless in san diego and also about sea
world so this one's so long that we're
gonna cut up in two parts
because nobody's gonna watch a six seven
minute clip on social media so we'll cut
into two parts i think the first part
will drop
tuesday tomorrow the second part drop
thursday on social you'll see it out
there though but i absolutely love san
diego
it's the one city um i would absolutely
move to 100
it's my vibe absolutely love san diego
there's something about san diego that i
absolutely love
um
it's a good time man went to the car
show malibu cars and coffees down there
if you click on the picture channel i
have the green jacket on
let's go past that now uh me and my
brother like to uh
argue which has a better car show san
diego or the one i go to malibu every
sunday
uh it'd be tough to beat san diego i
just i mean don't you wrong malibu has
money and people come from all around
there but uh
san diego especially this is like
outside san diego it i mean the money
out there is not so some dude this
billionaire drove up in a straight up if
your car guy you're like what the [ __ ]
his listen his daily driver is an
original shelby cobra
all silver has the
it was a race one like an original race
one his daily drive this thing's so loud
it's dude building a ponytail didn't
give [ __ ] driving through taco bell you
know it was sick that's this daily
driver man
um they had some insane cars out there
daddy saw one they want and it's for
sale too looking for uh like a 2006 f
430 daddy black 2006 spider yep 296
f430 spider
black
naturally uh aspirated
v8
0 to 16 about 4.1 4.2
i just love the look of them and
the
uh interiors like bit it's like one of
the bigger ones
so i'd fit in it but it'd be fun to mess
with what color you're saying black
black yeah it looks dope black
you power coat the rims gold like a
light gold like the gt2 rs rims
be pretty filthy be fun it should be a
fun car to mess around in really fun
nothing's dope looking right jim yeah
this looks sick yeah i've always wanted
one so we'll see
with inflation stuff we'll see if they
go down a little bit
like these that's exactly it but that
one is a hard top but that that would be
the color rims it's even a little darker
gold by the way down for that
[Music]
yeah
yeah similar black interior
spider though yeah it'd be fun it'd be
really fun you'll worry about the
transmission on those things
preferably you want to stick but then
you're talking about probably another
two three just for the stick ones that's
what the that's what everyone seeks is
the six speed and that
gear talk anyways um yeah man boy's
always on look um shout out to san diego
man got this fly ass jersey out there
got this fly ass san diego collab that
they did
um but yeah shout out to san diego i
freaking love it out there man
absolutely love it uh it was a great
time the laugh factory the green room
diaries i write thursday in the green
room that will drop like i said two part
series is a longer bit so that will drop
tomorrow and drop thursday and then uh
i got about a week off so i get this
week off from touring tour life and then
the following week um i've toured in
damn near every city except for this is
one of the few baltimore i've never been
to baltimore um only thing i know about
baltimore when i think of baltimore i
think of ray lewis and the ravens and i
think the show the wire
so somewhere between there is what i
think of baltimore which i've heard
nothing but great things here it's a
great club mcgoobies or some [ __ ] out
there yeah my goobies
um that's baltimore august 4th through
the 6th that's not this week it's the
following week thursday friday saturday
the funnest part is to try and find
airbnbs in baltimore
because in certain cities like i'm just
looking at chicago boston
um you know baltimore philly
you want to make sure you're in a good
area you feel me you want to make sure
you're in a good area so we'll see a lot
but the the baltimore's big military
town right
big military there's a military base
there
big military down there
but i think the military area is um
far from the from the club
yeah so you see um
the military is
i forget this is a major one there
yeah but if you go up to the map chin
there's like a lot of uh scroll out a
little bit
um
annapolis
ding ding ding mark for the win
annapolis yeah but that's annapolis like
an hour from the club so i can't stay
there although there's a ton of airbnb's
in annapolis
yeah that was the big boy out there
a lot of military in uh san diego too
that's my demo support military come
from military family what's up what's
poppin daddy excited to get to baltimore
though uh but we do have a fight
campaign this saturday
uh that is july 30th for ufc is it 278
or 277 ufc 277 pay-per-view
uh there will be a fight campaign july
30th and then as soon as i sign the
contract as soon as the ink dries i will
announce some big things as far as fight
companion goes
and i should be able to announce that
this week i would hope
um but yeah we're rocking we're we're
jiving and i also um
i mean you guys saw i think we put it
more on my uh instagram stuff like that
you definitely on the thick boy for most
stuff you guys should follow think boy
think boy has you know the instagram
there the boys here the staff came up
with the the idea dude thick boy fight
news
so
um you know they drop those news all the
time that's more of a
lot of stuff going on there you know
what i'm saying so as far as straight
news goes and stuff like that but um
they had some stuff i guess they really
put
i guess they put up with angela lee but
um thick boy
uh studios thick boy productions has
signed an exclusive deal to do um
content
uh fight campaigns for one championship
so you'll see us around there yeah it'll
be cool
yeah me and uh oh wow look at that
little little beef going on the thick
boy uh
social media there so what do we post
think boy fight news exclusive anjali
fires back at daniel kelly's remarks at
one championship presser
um and that uh angela
yeah daniel kelly too they didn't ask
her a ton of questions what they did she
came with heat
super heat so anjali put i would love to
beat you up
uh at daniel kelly bg bjj but i won't do
it for free there are much bigger fights
on focus on than a little grappling
match ooh okay a little shade there
facts are you're wanted on submission
grappling the organization once you
championship your talk uh you're talking
your talk and this is me talking mine
don't got time for your drama peace girl
and then she replied let's see if she
did there you go yep ashley your
insecurity speaks loud you look at your
next fight though
simple
but okay pretty savage
and we did a food truck with andrew lee
and rich franklin which will drop soon
too rich franklin was last time saw rich
franklin long time he's looking good is
he yeah looking good
he uh you know he's doing the damn thing
he's uh
uh he was he he's uh vice president of
one championship so he's in charge you
know a lot of stuff and they're coming
to america their big announcement is um
here's a podcast like quite frankly with
rich franklin
but um
he um
[Music]
yeah look at him he's pretty freaking
good as big but he um
you know one championship signed a deal
with amazon prime so they're doing five
uh big fights um that will be
broadcasted in america so they're i went
to this press conference i didn't
realize how big you know you hear the
you know all the talk about you know
international fights and stuff like that
i don't really you realize one champion
they're not even focused on the ufc like
you know me i'm
ufc is in my blood i'm using alumni i
know ufc better than any other
organization in sports you know what i'm
saying that's that's what i so i came up
and so so i know all of it so um
that's what i specialize in but you
always hear that one championship's big
internationally but also when i'm around
other fighters i usually bring you back
or correlate it to the ufc and one
champion she's like hey dude shut up
like we
we're not even focused on them and they
show me the nelson ratings like
internationally how much bigger their
views are
it's like there's one
like
thing bigger than them internationally
and then it's them
the ufc is like sixth or seventh they're
like you what are you talking about go i
don't know what i'm talking about so i
should probably do some research on that
they have 6.8 million followers on
instagram
but yeah they're doing the damn thing
and the the first big fight will be
friday august 26th it's mariah's uh and
dj demetrius johnson and that is the the
rematch yeah
dude you don't realize how big marias is
i mean he is way bigger than dj he's a
big freaking dude man my boy marcus
almeida you know him as bushesha
bushesha 19 yeah 19 time world champion
grappler i think he's 3-0 in mma now
he's a beast
super beast so it's fun being around one
championship i mean i originally i drove
down to the press conference on
wednesday before i left for san diego uh
because me and chacha were supposed to
sit down and go over things but he uh
got coveted
so it's me and rich franklin
but uh shot to one championship man
looking forward to it we got a bunch of
a bunch more big announcements come to
thick boy productions we just getting
started doug and your boy is exhausted
oh i have insomnia now so that's cool
how's up in four days what's up
let's take a little break from me just
chatting about fisticuffs
speaking of breaks i am not taking a
break or i'll be on tour trash panda
summer tour continues baltimore august
4th through the 6th get your tickets at
thickboy.com and chicago one night only
august 26 at the den theater it's a
friday night in chicago one show only
come get some thickboy.com
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep
you know what man i need sleep now more
than ever and i i stay at airbnbs i
sleep in hotels and your boy if i'm not
sleeping on a helix mattress i don't
sleep great that's why i look like this
right now your boy has not been sleeping
at home on my helix sleep mattress it is
the best mattress you will ever put your
body on listen helix sleep has a quiz
that takes two minutes to complete
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress just
for you now for every joe schmoe out
there this mattress is designed and
built just for you you a side sleeper
tummy sleeper back sleeper they got it
all man you don't need to take my word
for it helix was awarded the number one
best overall overall mattress of
2019-2020 by gq and wired magazine all
right i have them at my house the only
matches i mess with just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz they'll
match you with a perfect mattress that's
just built for your body and will give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10-year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up if you don't
love it but you will so don't worry
about it helix is offering the shop show
listeners and viewers to 200 off all
mattress orders and free pillows for the
listeners and viewers of this show
helixsleep.com
that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200 off man a
lot of you got vacations lined up or
you're just trying to get shredded for
the summer and you're like oh it's
already july i mean started man i don't
know what to do
my train i don't be at the gym around
other people i don't have a good trainer
well guess what
i'm gonna let you in a little secret
your boy's been using fitbot that's
right fitbot smart workout app gives you
custom tailored workouts you need to
keep the burn going all summer long
winter long
fall long spring long whatever it is
my friends at fit bodz got you covered
man all right whether you're just
getting started or you're
a veteran of the gym you know every
workout
from fitbot is designed to push you to
the next level it's not the repetitive
boring no no no whatever sets you got
going on you want some progress you're
gonna see all that man it's custom to
make sure you're getting the most
efficient workout possible all right
fitbot smart workout app creates a
custom dynamic program based on your
goals experience and the equipment that
you have available all right their
algorithm uses data analytics to build
your best next workout maximize results
every workout is scientifically proven
to be better than the last and it's
crazy this app is super easy to use it
has hd video tutorials that make
learning new exercises super easy your
trainer is in your phone now from fitbot
man crush your summer fitness goals with
personalized workouts from fitbot that
improves as you do get 25 off your
subscription or try out the app for free
when you sign up right now at
fitbot.me
shobb that's 25 off your subscription or
try for free at
fitbot.me
shop s-c-h-a-u-b fit pod let's get to
the fights man
uh you have the big ufc
277
this saturday again we are doing a fight
campaign for it but over the weekend you
had ufc london
um
i
and i could be honest this free fight
night in london the previous ufc uh
london was stacked this one was stacked
these free fight nights in
london are better than the pay-per-views
that we get in america this card was is
more stacked more entertaining than the
pay-per-view
on saturday but there are some really
good fights on saturday which we'll get
to but uh going back to saturday's ufc
london which was i think start at 10 a.m
prelims start at 10 a.m or 9 a.m the
early period yeah
so i was able to watch it um
live which is always a blessing you
watch from the freaking airbnb and chill
in your underoos and freaking
have nicotine drink that coke so um
ufc london again
because the ufc london previously to
this was the first time they were back
in london the lockdown stuff like that
and it was so many finishes i think it
was all finishes
and you know patty pillett was on that
um and so was uh um
molly meatball mccann so
you know
all those finishes and then you're doing
it again so i think there was kind of
some hype you know that people thought
maybe you get the same thing but it'd be
tough to duplicate that energy or and
that excitement from the you the first
ufc london this one was good
and you know i think the biggest
takeaways from all this is
patty pimlet
is hands down
if he was a stock you would put all your
money on him this kid is a bona fide
mother trucking
superstar
and the ufc knows that
and um
you know this
ufc london was kind of
hampered because the the main event
obviously tom aspinall blew his knee out
and there's 15 seconds the first round
so whenever that happens there's a
little bit of you know cast shadow over
the entire card but you know besides
that main event that this main card was
pretty poppin man you know ozdamir um
beat paul craig um i actually picked
paul craig in that um
molly uh meatball mccann did her
freaking thing another spinning elbow
you know um and obviously her and paddy
pimlet go together like peanut butter
and jelly you know what i'm saying uh
molly uh molly the meatball and patty
pillman go together like fish and chips
out there they are just
must-see tv so they had her on um you
know second into the main card uh oz de
mer paul craig important fight big fight
for light heavyweight division osman
gets it done didn't think he was gonna
win that one good for him uh then molly
kicks it off and the crowd goes [ __ ]
bananas right and then krylov absolutely
destroys alexander gusfin
i'm sure you've seen it dc i think maybe
bisping from the other uh uh mma heads
we're talking about this he doesn't need
to stop you know he probably should stop
he's just
you don't want to be around too long you
know and i don't know how much he wants
to do it anymore but you're talking
about one the best ever do it he if he
was just born a little later he's you
know regards the greatest light
heavyweight of all time but [ __ ] happens
and you come up at the same time as jon
jones in dc did and here we are you're
the third greatest well done you know so
nothing to hang your head about but i
freaking love gus finn but i would like
to see him stop
um so he had the guessing card he gets
absolutely annihilated
and then let's be honest the main event
walks out
and the the crowd was
so loud
and you know bisping said this on uh the
bt sport breakdown which one of my
favorite shows
he goes you guys hear how loud it is on
tv he goes i'm telling you i've been he
was personally in my career i've been
part of big fights especially in london
i've seen everybody's walk out and then
now as an analyst i see the big boys
walked out nothing is even close to a
paddy pillmitt walk out it's like i've
never seen anything like it
and i just think
you know for patty pimlet uh you know
fighting at 155 obviously a stack
division um jordan levitt definitely his
toughest fight yet you know 12-1 solid
wrestler patty had some issues in the
first round but he did in the first
round on his back you know did it
doesn't matter can you go the scorecard
you would prob maybe give that round to
jordan even though patty took his back
you know at the end of the round there
but uh don't be too buy so let's say
patty lost that first round you know in
the second round he gets it done with
that slick uh rear naked choke and the
kid definitely has skills um on the
ground you guys knew this but um
it's kind of good for him he's just not
steamrolling through all these guys and
you know it's
a cakewalk for him because he's learning
from all this he's learning from all
this and he
kind of was ah it's tough to say i i
don't say he's a slow starter but it
takes him a while before you really
bring out the best in patty pimlet and i
think jordan levitt did that um
[Music]
but it couldn't be more obvious that he
is the most famous
by far in most demand by far must-see tv
it's
couldn't be any clear for the ufc that
he needs to be main event
you know he's overshadowing the card he
could sell this if it was just patty vs
jordan he sells this thing out so um
i do think the ufc needs to take
notice of that and they do and i'm not
saying anything they don't know um but
patty moving forward now needs to be
main event he's a main event fighter he
is
hands down top six
uh most famous most
must-see fighters on the roster
but this is this where yet he's he's
towing a fine line
because in the lightweight division
would i list padding the top
15 no no not yet but that's the nature
of the beast everyone wants to see you
know patty uh machichev patty dustin
poury patty justin gaichi like jesus
christ man
in the ufc you know they've they've have
in the in the past they've learned from
the mistakes they rushed uh darren till
and they've rushed other guys
we'll get to it about um
sugar shawn are they rushing him i have
a
take on that where i don't think they're
rushing him but you know to go from
a fight or poking the guy in the eye and
uh pedro munoz then going to the number
one contender
it's a little extreme but also the ufc
like what he wants to do man what do you
want to do
how long should we keep bringing this
guy up so
at a certain point i kind of agree with
ufc you know it's kind of [ __ ] or get
off the pot i think that's going on with
with sugar shawn he's such a massive
star and he's also a guy who makes a lot
of money outside the octagon he's also a
guy
who they have brought up slow
but at some point you we gotta let's see
what we got that's what the ufc is doing
i
it's weird i kind of agree with him on
this one i think a lot of people like oh
my god you believe they're doing that
that's my initial reaction is you look
more into it and you focus on like
i get what they're doing like all right
let's see can can we put the company's
brand and the name behind it make him
the face of the ufc as other guys are
retiring and yet you know nate diaz you
know has one fight and you know a lot of
these other fighters aren't very active
so
i think it for for the ufc it's a matter
of all right see what we got let's put
him against this guy now
peter you're on the number one guy
a little extreme little extreme but
stylistically if peter young fancy
himself a striker and you know he is the
shorter fighter i can see how uh uh sri
shanks can win can win that fight
now just because they did that to sugar
sean
doesn't mean you keep the same energy
with patty pimlet you for patty
you know you he he still has some things
to work on he still has a ways to go
he's not on sugar's level sugar has had
many fights in the ufc and passed a lot
of tests he did lose to cheeto vera um
you know so
just because they did that with sugar
don't put that pressure on patty patty
has work to do he will get there he has
the skill set to be a world champion but
he needs more experience tougher
opponents jordan levitt definitely a
tough opponent yet at 12 and one but
give him time let let him grow man let
him grow but you but you again it's a
fine line but you can let him grow as a
main event he is
a bona fide
stupid superstar he is the fifth beatle
for a reason he he can get any bigger
because here's the thing about patty
you guys will watch his interviews and
see the clips on instagram or social
media you know that kid's irrigate i get
you i was
kind of on that same boat before i met
him
and then i meet him we do a food truck
together it's on the thick boy network
right now you can watch it
when how did i do a food truck
instantly you meet the kid yo oh he has
it and it's not
forced it's not uh preconceived you know
kind of hot takes or it's not wwe it's
just him
he just has it and these type of guys
come around once in a lifetime and you
saw it with connor and you can see it
with some other guys but patty has it
man patty freaking has it he's such a
good person
that deep down to his core he's such a
good person he actually believes what
he's saying he's entertaining his gift
of gab and you know he's uh he's a
liverpool badass man he's the liverpool
thick boy and he uh
he just has it
he just does it's hard to to find and
when you find it you [ __ ] dude you
hang on to it that's what the ufc needs
to do but he is just a bona fide
superstar and he's only getting bigger
and
i think obviously his performance you
got to win you got to win none of this
matters and now we're talking about you
know what's next for him if he were to
lose and how he needs to recoup and do
all the stuff
but we're not talking about that we're
talking you know you got to take care of
business first which he has you know
he's undefeated in the ufc
but to me what makes patty even bigger
stars than he gets on the mic
and he says his uh good friend committed
suicide
uh and he got a text at 4am right before
he has to kill all that weight and now
patty is different than a lot of
lightweights because his fight starts
with the weight cut because he does like
to get really big between fights
so him cutting weight is a fighting in
itself
now not only cutting mass amount of
weight and you know every calorie counts
and you know you're sweating your ass
off but then your good mate committed
suicide
imagine dealing with that before and
let's be honest you're the main event in
ufc london
o2 arena it's a big freaking deal for
these guys man so
for him to be able to combat that
and still go out and perform and and
wait to address that just shows you what
level of superstar you're working with i
don't think a lot of guys could deal
with that now i don't know how good of a
friend it is but he was a good enough
friend
that you know he's he's crying in his
post fight uh press conference and
again i think the thing that really made
him a superstar is he gets on and speaks
from the heart and talks about you know
mental illness and how you know there's
some weird thing with dudes that you
know it shows weakness if we talk about
our mental health struggles and stuff
like that and patty goes i'd rather you
cry my shoulder than me going to a
funeral next week so
um and none of that was preconceived you
can tell he
you know busy being's asking questions
he was can i talk for a second and then
rift just rips that promo about mental
health and strength commitment suicide
jesus christ
just when you think you'd like him
anymore he does this
you know he's a real badass man real
badass so shout out to patty pamela what
i do think is next for him is
main events main event or best for him
uh ufc knows that um
but he's already captured the the uk
market you know he's the biggest star
out there
the biggest [ __ ] star i told you the
owner of uh uh cage warriors who
bisping connor dan hardy aspinall all
these monsters come out of right molly
all these monsters
because i've been with everybody man
we've never had a bigger star than patty
not even close oh really he was not even
close dude
holy [ __ ] because it's nuts when he's in
liverpool he can't even walk the streets
he's [ __ ] he's def we call him and
that's where i got we call him the fifth
beatle he cannot walk the streets
holy [ __ ] he's kidding us yeah dude
never seen anything like it it was even
when connor was here kind of he was
doing it around connor big deal
nobody bigger than patty come on
big deal so for for patty you have that
uk market
now for the ufc it's you know you're
bringing him to uh mass square guard and
you bring him to you know the big boy
pay-per-views that's what you doing he's
the main event
you know if you have patty versus molly
meatball mccann you know obviously again
they're fish and chips they're peanut
butter and jelly put those two as the
main event co-main event we put patty's
the main event and just have molly
somewhere on the the pay-per-view card
that [ __ ] selling out so now it's
bringing him over to the american fans
which he's already pretty big here but
he could easily put him in mass square
garden at the end of the year he wants
to fight at the end of the year so
i i assume that's the next step for him
is really
integrating him into the american market
american's gonna love him how can he not
and then uh co-main event you have jack
hermeson versus chris curtis
um
you know the fights i got wrong were i i
always picked gus finn because i'm
biased as [ __ ] i used to train with
guess when i love gusman and then uh i
picked paul craig over at osmer so i get
those two wrong uh i did pick jack
hermeson to beat chris curtis uh not
like this though not stand up you know i
thought he was going to take him down
and out grappling but it was a striking
fest and jack hermansen got a huge win
over chris curtis short notice opponent
so i think also the takeaway from that
is is is how good sean strickland is who
was able to utilize a jab and be jack
emerson that's how good shawn strickland
is i know you guys saw him get knocked
out by that world-class kickboxer and
peter and his ego got to him but
strickland's pretty [ __ ] good
especially after you see his performance
against chris curtis you're like oh [ __ ]
that's more it's a good win it's a very
good one um
so you know i think darren till kind of
got away with one here not fighting this
fight her mansion like phenomenal dude
and did it
with striking so uh the biggest takeaway
is chris curtis just needs better
footwork you got to cut off the [ __ ]
cage dude you're chasing this guy so he
has some work to do
you know and then the the main event the
the let down there is um you know tom
aspinall blew his goddamn knee out in 15
seconds and you're talking a big strong
guy who's not the most animated dude and
he is yelling and crying inside that
octagon
um i think
there's nothing official yet but from
what i'm here it's the mcl tear which
you know thank god to uh modern um
i guess science and technology and and
and advancement in medicine because
usually i'd be a career ender but he'll
be back
even if he blew that entire mcl out
which they believe he did you know
six to eight months
he'll be back
so you know it's not an ideal thing for
curtis blades because curtis blades
tom aspinall which i hate the fight for
tom anyways and even the 15 seconds
you're like oh we got to fight here
those boys are throwing um you know but
you wanted whoever it's that there's no
way that thing was gonna go five rounds
the way they came out firing at each
other which we wanted to see it and i'd
love to see that rematch and i'm not a
guy who likes to see rematches when
stuff like this happens but i would love
to see that fight ran back
the shame is is you have kind of this
heavyweight tournament going on with
cyril gone tied to
and tom aspinall and then you have
on the other side of the bracket too you
have jon jones and stephen and then you
have your champ francis and he's
freaking things out come from an injury
and chasing the tyson fury fight so you
have all these weird dynamics going on
but in this tournament
curtis blade's tom asimov was kicking it
off
and
whoever won this it's a big deal you're
right up there and
you wanted that rub off of the finish
the highlight of the finish to sell the
next fight tom astronaut blows his
[ __ ] mcl out
so chris plays like here we go you know
so technically he did win
but um
it's not the way you want to win and
it's tough to sell his next fight but it
is a win so shout out to curtis blades
you know you flew down there blue's
[ __ ] nail freak accidents
it's just
you know this is what the third time
this has happened because thinking about
last main event in long island you know
brian ortega yay rodriguez brian ortega
blew his shoulder out
due to submission but you could all say
tom astronauts was due to the striking
of cursed blades he was reacting and
going backwards and blew his knee out
and that's why it's a tko so you have
curtis blades
um tom aspinall fight ends in a freak
accident you have brian ortega
less of a freak accent i told you on
last week's episode i think it's more of
yahya rodriguez applying pressure on the
shoulder but either way you have a
premature stoppage
and prior to that
you have even you know
i don't say baker fight but big fight uh
with a superstar in sugar sean and
pedro munoz and pedro can't go on to ipo
you know his eye was [ __ ] up it's
three enrollment we got a problem it's
not the way you want to get things done
obviously ufc just goes yep that
happened that guy had to win we're gonna
move on because the ufc went all right
sugar sean
technically you beat pedro munoz
you know the number whatever seven guy
in the division
we'll take that as a win and you gotta
finish so here's peter young you know so
that's where ufc is viewing this stuff
so i think for
uh curtis blades he's in a big time
fight i i i would imagine he gets the
winner of uh cyril gone and taito
taitu avasta which both good matchups
were
um
and then uh
you got jon jones and stephen doing
their thing and then france is out for a
hot second recovering from that you know
knee surgery and chasing the tyson fight
and contract issues so
and also even even with the jair
rodriguez you know he blew or take his
shoulder out even though a lot of the
the
narrative is there's
pre-stoppage due to an injury again i
think it was a submission victory
the ufc no matter how you feel about it
reward him go we'll probably get title
shot probably interim tile against
emmett or something like that you know
so
they're they're uh rewarding these guys
even though they're not getting it done
the way we want to but it doesn't matter
so
um fun card overall but don't let that
main event bump me out i feel terrible
for tom asking yeah
well curtis even won a record saying
that he's not going to give him the
rematch because
he did beat him and he says that he
doesn't want to risk his ranking by also
waiting for time to get heal up and then
fighting him yeah
no [ __ ] no you know wait for tom asked
to recover from mcl surgery no no
because place has to move on the the the
show continues i don't care who you are
show continues yeah
um yeah good card again i thought this
card was better than the the paper you
this saturday for ufc 277
um
ufc 277 i think it's in dallas
it's in texas this is in texas yeah
american airlines center american
airlines yeah i'm pretty sure that's
dallas so that place looks sweet by the
way when you drive by it
i'm surprised to put dirk lewis uh on
this card not only put derrick lewis on
the card they gave him a [ __ ] tough
matchup against their sergey pavilig
pavilion pavlovich pavlovich they gave
him a tough matchup
and he obviously struggles when he
fights at home he's such a better
fighter outside
texas
you know especially when he's fighting
top
top of the spare guys
i don't know why they do it you know
again sarah gone he was like i just
didn't want to be there i didn't show up
and then so he doesn't perform in that
one now all right let's run it back in
texas i think it was houston here's
taito vasa and taito vasa you know lance
when the elbow is brutal so
you know
he's on he's on a tough track man i
don't i just i don't know if his team
asks for this or what i just
it's obviously a mental
kind of
block for him when he fights at home and
they put him back on her gets a very
[ __ ] tough opponent um i think he's
slightly favored but i would not bet on
him in this you know
minus 110 and he's it's even money yeah
minus 10 minus i get that you don't know
what version of dick was gonna show up
in texas
sergey is a [ __ ] tough opponent for
him in texas
um
the i'm excited for that fight if derek
lewis gets his mind right it's a
phenomenal fight uh the other kind of
one you want to start on this is the one
that kicks off the main event which is
anthony smith versus uh
goliath
you know for anthony smith you know he's
won three in a row uh magamed is a
[ __ ] he's like makachev you know what
i'm saying he's like much of but way
bigger he's a [ __ ] problem and you
know auntie smith is a pretty big
underdog in this um
i can't pick against aunt smith
obviously i'm biased i think anthony
smith gets it done i i think anthony
smith has fought tougher opponents he
has uh a tougher strength of schedule
and he has passed that test and with um
magmetta mugham ed you know minus 490
plus 390 a light heavyweight yeah that's
not good for anthony smith you know but
i think anthony smith is going to find a
way to get it done and he's on a streak
right now he feels a little uh
you know he feels the type of way about
the way the light heavyweight
conversation is going right now so
the other thing going back to curtis
blades i forgot to mention keep note
that curtis blades and jon jones are
talking [ __ ] to each other
yeah there's something there there's
something there um depending how john
looks against stipe
there couldn't be a worse matchup for
cursed blades john can wrestle oh so if
your curtis blades and your first strike
with a much ranger longer jon jones you
can't get him down
tough fight that fight but you know
chris blades has a i'd say a power
um advantage but outside that on the
feet
and you know
he he's a he's a double leg guy
explosive double leg guy
be careful man john double leg me tough
very very tough you guys know how high
i'm on jon jones i think he's the best
to ever [ __ ] do it so
um but yeah back to the the ufc 277
pay-per-view um you know i'm rooting for
anthony smith to give him a tough
[ __ ] fight he's the biggest dog on
the main card um
alexander and alex perez perez
you know perez had the great showing
um you know but he's he's been inactive
you know he fought figarito uh for the
flyweight championship and he lost in
the first round
um you know so i don't see a great
showing but you know his last fight was
for the title he's been out two years so
being inactive and jumping right into
the deep end i hate that
um tough fight for alex very tough fight
but notice they're on this for a reason
because you have the interim title fight
going on with brian moreno and kai care
of france
kaiker france and brandon moreno have
fought before and brian moreno beat them
via decision they've both gotten a lot
better since then
um
but make no
um kind of its ends or butts about it
they've both gotten better and brenton
moreno beat him even back in the day i i
would assume brandon does it again you
know
and the main event
listen with julia pena and amanda nunes
this is you know i i think you're if you
look at the last fight juliana pena went
into that fight going i'm going to win
this it was like you're not you know
it's one of the biggest upsets in ufc
history as far as odd makers go but
you know is it is it a case there's so
much going on in his life you know one
of the greatest ever dude if not the
greatest
i think most
of the fight committee has her as the
greatest female fighter of all time
so um she's a favorite in this minus 275
which just a lack of respect for juan
pena
um you know
if you're going to battle this fight
you're hoping it's a uh an old school
version of amanda nunes not the
successful one who has everything you
know recently you know she's married
she's kid she has new gym now she has
money in the bank so
how bad does amanda nunez wants it i
don't know if i'm willing to bet on that
you know i think julian pena if you
watch that back to the first fight you
know it's not like julia beat the [ __ ]
out of her you know i i think we're more
surprised how well she was doing so
in this rematch i was assuming this
takes a little more serious if you are
going to bet on it that's what you're
betting on that she
isn't overlooking july opinion she
realizes she can be beat she's focused
at a solid training camp and if it's a
vintage amanda nunes yeah she'll
probably win but um i just think
father time has caught up with her
success maybe caught up with her july
opinion is more hungry
and also july opinion you beat her once
that was a fluke so now she has
something to prove where she is the
better fighter so you know i'll take
july opinion man i i think she gets it
done and that that's i'm saying that
and i'm not crazy confident but i am
saying that because i i do think july
opinion right now in current
freaking was it july 25th on monday is a
better fighter
two years ago a man this yeah all day
but now if all the time success juan
pena wants it more she's hungry she's an
underdog again even though she beat her
you know so disrespectful
so i'll take you my opinion
uh drew drew dobers on the undercarriage
i'm never mad at so again this thing's
not gonna blow your [ __ ] hair back
let's take another break here on the
shop show cause this saturday
you have a big old ufc pay-per-view ufc
277 you also have a combat fight
companion 7pm pacific live on thick boy
youtube but you know what
you can watch ufc 277 and you can bet
with the best and can make some bank
while watching with your bros bruce bros
and bank that's right do with draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the ufc this saturday new
customers can bet five dollars on any
fighter to win and get 100 in free bets
win or lose
want even more action cool you can also
double your winnings on a same game
parlay all right same fight parley they
say game i say fight combine multiple
bets like which fighter will win how
long the fight will last
do they get a finish do they go to
decision whatever it is combine multiple
bets all right just place your ufc 277
same game parlay if it hits you win
double draftkings is safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code shop show sch
aub show bet 5 on any ufc 277 fighter to
win and get 100 in free bets no matter
what that's code shop show this saturday
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports brand partner of the ufc minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
seashell notes for details see next page
for directions for disclaimers hey if
you're like me i took french in high
school i don't know a lake of french you
send me to pierce right now i will get
lost i can't understand french i can't
speak french
i'm also married to a mexican wife she
only speaks spanish it's a disaster
but then my friends at babel said yo fam
we got you covered you want to know all
the bad stuff your family staying behind
your back at these barbecues i mean i
sure do but i'm 38 i can't learn a new
language they went
you got to try babel dude the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions all right it's
easy it's easy to digest babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons that
actually you'll use not like this in
school where you learn all this random
stuff nope nope
listen your boy is taking spanish
babble's 15-minute lessons i do it while
i drive to work 15-minute lessons make
it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go and other language
learning apps use ai for the lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts we gotcha and
their methods they're scientifically
proven to be effective and fun as well
babel you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish your boy
french in high school italian and german
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve
on everything including your accent all
right there's so many ways to learn with
babble right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you get
an additional three months free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com use promo code shop
s-c-h-a-b that's babel
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com code is shop
a little quick picture this is pretty
cool after the fight tom aspinall and
curtis blade shared a beer a couple
beers yeah good for them man
good for them i love that
uh all right we talked about this on
fire in the kid but not i'm really here
yet
nate diaz hamza so they verbally agreed
but it's on the ufc website so oh it's
happening yeah no this is official this
is official as it gets it it says on
finally kids if brett akamoto tweets it
out it's official he's the the sound
piece to dana white they're coming to
him with breaking news yeah he used to
be ariel that's brad akamoto so if he
blasts this out it you can bet your
bottom dollar is [ __ ] happening so
until i hear from him i'm really i'm
always like yeah i don't know but with
this it's definitely having obviously
it's happened the ufc has another
goddamn website
so you have hamzad versus nate diaz and
i think a lot of especially nate diaz
fans are pissed off because they're like
oh this is how you repay a guy after 15
years of hard work in the ufc
from a business decision the fc is going
yeah dude we've offered him fights he
you know he's up for the homs out fight
he thinks he can beat hamzad
and hamza we think is the next big thing
nate diaz is a
massive superstar so this is what we do
they've done this to fighters
all the they do this all the time it's
the young
line prospect from sweden via chechnya
versus nate diaz you know the older more
famous more well-known guy and all
they're trying to do is get nate diaz
fan base to tune in to watch hamza and
capture captures from that fan base
that's what's going on here
at the same time too if i'm if i'm dana
white
you know people think he's throwing
shade on the ideas going he's won one
fight in six years dude we're trying to
find a fight you know you're out of your
mind you think he's fighting izzy or
francis or you know fighting the
champions it doesn't make any sense he's
won one fight in [ __ ] six years so
what he wants to do
and you know nate diaz has been throwing
shade at dana and stuff like that so
danny goes okay
okay here's hamza
you want to fight here's homs
it's literally the worst matchup we
could think of for crazy
now we know you're just gonna do this
because you went out of your contract
and go on to fight jake palm that's fine
but you're gonna walk through some
[ __ ] fire
some
chechnyan via sweden [ __ ] fire and
this kid is good
all around good
but i like chaos and i think it would be
hilarious if nathan has won
hilarious hilarious
i don't think you know it doesn't hurt
the uh jake paul fight if even if nate
were to get mollywop don't think it
hurts it nate's so goddamn tough though
you know he's gonna take some of
hamzad's best shots but hamzat if he
fancy himself a brawler again like you
did against uh gilbert burns
you know if if it's a brawl if if hamza
goes i'm just going to try and destroy
this guy i'm going to get in the [ __ ]
fist cuffs uh you know a phone booth
fight
i'll put some money on the ideas
i think nae diaz is a better boxer 100
better boxer now
he's not younger he doesn't hit us hard
he doesn't have all the assets you know
to to
go toe-to-toe with homs up but if hamza
fights stupid nate diaz does have the
experience in the big fight experience
to pull some out of his ass i think it
would be hilarious
chance that happening not good
hamza is a minus 12 50.
that is a phantom
but also
right on
spot you know
top [ __ ] the gear couldn't be a worse
matchup for an atheist
[ __ ] with bull you're gonna get the
horse and that's what he did that's what
the ufc is doing you know i said some
fighting kid you know when this fight
got announced and then the trigger sean
verse um
peter yon
you know dana woke up was like oh it's
[ __ ] wednesday that's what this is
and he called his ufc employees like hey
guys so i got two fights for you we got
uh hamzat nate diaz uh and trigger sean
petery on like jesus christ
and then jake papa uh better believe i'm
putting my money on eight years to win
versus fake to be oh interesting
interesting i don't know if he's typing
he's hyping up his fight when they do
yeah that's all he's doing
what else you got then
that's september 10th
i wonder if i'm in town then september's
so busy
it is
it's a uh
it's going on sale july 29th september
10th and it's um
timo vegas yeah
i'm in appleton wisconsin
okay that's cool
i'd love to do a companion for that
[Music]
what else got you
this is a quick one on
i haven't heard from lauren's larkin in
a long time but from who lorenz larkin
oh he's on the show yeah i love lauren
so does this take on jake paul when you
have fn youtubers renting out staple
center having box matches and you have
these fighters like jake bahu let's be
honest he can fight for where he's at
and the guys he's fighting don't have a
boxing background that's not true uh for
these type of guys to come in it just
changes combat sports makes people think
oh i can do that [ __ ] you won't be like
hey dude i'm an athlete i can go [ __ ]
heads up with warren sapp or [ __ ] ray
lewis very old school references deep
call back
he didn't want to go current huh
even j.j white you know yeah or or
donald or aaron uh donald that'd be more
relevant or von miller
whatever he said warren sapper ray lewis
you wouldn't think that you'd be like
[ __ ] no
yeah
[Music]
and i didn't hear from lorenz in a long
time but he's not doing too bad in
bellator
no he it it started off rough for him
and then now he's been on it he's been
on the go now yeah he's been doing the
damn thing
all right you already covered sean maui
pedrion but
so algerian sterling versus tj dillashaw
is being moved to that car yeah ooh
doggy
enjoy that fellas enjoy that long trip
so that's one matchup that's moved there
yeah for sugar shawn you know i do think
stylistically in the top three peter
yana's best matchup going wrong it's a
tough [ __ ] fight for him to be an
underdog but there are ways for him to
win that
my whole thing with this is i would say
the ufc is a a marathon not a sprint for
longevity
you know so if you were to get past pj
on we got al jermaine sterling tj
dillashaw waiting for you and then boys
can wrestle so we'll see yeah
i'm excited to see it a little bit with
ufc because how many ufc fights does
sugar have
let's see him
you look it up he has a pretty
you know and outside the ufc he has
fights too so it's not like he's some
young young buck i think it's the ufc
going all right let's see if we can bet
on you man
since the contender series since 2017.
he has won two
and i'm counting the ufc contender
series so he has one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten fights in efc
that's a lot of fights dude
that's a good amount of fights
yeah good enough to
again how they slow played them which is
great
now the ufc is going it's time to get
off the spot let's see what we got here
because
diaz is leaving um other guys are
leaving we need the new crop of
superstars that we can bank on let's see
if sugar is that guy that's all they're
doing
i'm not mad at it i think sure can win
the fight yeah there is some capacity
where he can win yeah the length yeah
the the
he's unpredictable the the footwork sure
is a beast
all right on that same card uh
benilderius has a new partner oh gamrot
that's a great fight yep
great fight
and this one here
not official but michael chandler's kind
of teasing that he's going to be
fighting pory
we did a food truck with mike chandler
drops this wednesday we talked about it
i think
you know i told him this on the food
truck you know i said uh you know it's
the fight business and i think
for him you know he's the only name that
is being brought up when you refer to
conor mcgregor and ideas right
and he's like yeah but you know that's
great and all but i would i want to i
want to be a world champion i get all
that you know you could but you could
fight both those guys
get that fan base kept you know capture
that fan base capture that momentum and
then
you know once we figure out who's the
champ then go over them fight that
because if you beat those guys you get
those fights
your your profile goes through the
[ __ ] roof the ufc can bank on you
which they already are because he brings
you know entertainment and coming off
that
knockout of the year against tony
ferguson you fight you know nate diaz
and uh conor mcgregor and then you go
fight for it
you know he's a fighters fighter and he
wanted he's like yeah i'd love to you
know if much to ever win i'd love to get
that michael jeff fight first i'm like
daddy you got two kids now you just
stopped another baby of two kids like
make your money dude you're the only guy
that's in both conversations there's a
real possibility those could happen so
if you look at chandler you know he has
possible next fights you have dustin
poirier
he has um
they diaz but that's gone right so
really is doesn't boy nathan has just
got to fight his last fight so that's
not happening you're never gonna see
nate diaz michael challenge it's not
happening then you have conor mcgregor
you know so
depend when conor wants to come back and
i'll see the connor trilogy fights i
have with the ideas so connor's
definitely a possibility for him
depending on the the health of conor
mcgregor's leg and then you have uh
dustin poiret not bad
if you're a michael chandler fan not bad
at all
so him for support is a big fight
big fight now
out of nate diaz
conor mcgregor and does pory it's the
least
kind of
big name fight but still big f that's
quite a massive name massive massive so
good fight for chandler and there's beef
there you know he talked about the
altercation they had at the the ufc so
you'll hear it on food truck on
wednesday that's good
and then the the fourth one in the next
match of room is is you know if moksha
were to get by charles oliveira that'd
be the next fight for him so you know
makchev justify or conor not bad yeah
not bad if you're a chandler fan what
does sketching this right here so
alexander rakitch and jimmy manuel were
at the london event and then alexander
saying that jimmy manoa sucker punched
him there
that's not good
interactive
right you piece of [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] man what a [ __ ] move
you did last night on me
guys i'll just let you know that uh
after the event at ufc london
i was escorting uh the securities
escorting me to the transfer to the
hotel back to the hotel and mr still
sleep was sitting in my row at the end
of the row so i needed to pass him by
and i passed by and
he talked to me something i didn't
really pay attention first and the
second
i have nothing to do with that guy you
know for me
this is over so i started to turn away
and he sucker punched me and even in
that close range he couldn't catch my
head i think he hit me with the four
arm on my neck and the securities were
so fast here and they separate us man
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] move you knew that
i'm be alone in london by myself you
knew that i had surgery nine weeks ago
and you did this
man you're such a bad bad loser and i
want to people know
what a piece of [ __ ] you are you know
i'm gonna stay in your head forever i
retire you
i knocked you out
and the world saw that so
happy retirement mr sleep
yes
yes there's some online comments yeah i
guess uh oh gmano's accusing rocketch of
dming him like you know i ko you or
something and also do you need some
money because you know he won 50k for it
yeah yeah so man it's a fighter's
fighter yeah i'm saying he's a real
tough dude he said he would stop mano
said he would slap him in the public if
he saw him so actually he said it was a
slap and it wasn't an actual sucker
punch i'd rather get punched
had to give him what he deserves for
acting like a troll interesting yeah
um
it's just a quick one here
who's saying this this is yair yeah yeah
rodriguez says volkowski had the
opportunity to face me before he decided
to fight korean zombie that's why i was
upset from the top five i'm one of the
guys that he hasn't fought i think that
would be a great fight i respect the
champ a lot yeah 100
yeah
and let me jump to this
that person has a good point go back
this guy put guys one-on-one in like
three years with that win being ortega's
shoulder popping out see i disagree
there's a submission why has he been
talking about a title shot so much based
on what
not a bad take
and this is bryce milch bryce mitchell
can i fight yahair and get a total shot
after i win because if so i will do that
i would love bryce mitchell to fight
yeah yeah i think he beats yeah yeah
i do too
all right uh
what's up someone says price for
stronghold allen if yeah i see it
taking away two young lines
even our old allen versus yay here sign
me up
uh i guess daniel
cory was talking to
i'm not sure where but so he said that
at one point uh one of the jon jones
fights it did so well that dana white
told him hey i'm gonna give you a
million dollars on top of whatever he
got paid yeah and the next day he got a
check for a million dollars so his dad
comes two days later hey man you all
killed it numbers are out of this world
he goes we're gonna send a million bucks
this is 2015. dude sent me a million
i'll check the next day just because he
said i did a great job
well
yeah yeah dude you fought john i mean
that's the least you could do i mean
it's cool he did that yeah but also you
know how much money they made for him to
come and give you a million bucks dc
you know still dope though it's dope the
problem was back in the day when that
stuff would happen i mean that's dope
but you couldn't like
i found those days so 2015
i think it's probably when i retired but
you know those days those undisclosed
discretionary bonuses
we had no idea who was giving what
sometimes you get it sometimes you
wouldn't sometimes you you know you get
a little something sometimes you get a
lot you just it was nerve-wracking
you couldn't depend on anything
you know especially if you're on the
main card you did always give a
discussion bonus you know but you had no
clue it might be five thousand dollars
might be fifty thousand dollars might be
a hundred thousand dollars maybe a
million bucks we had no clue
i always wonder what the actual money
was how much money are you saying like
as low as
yeah it could be as low as five grand
yeah if you're on the main card as low
as five grand but also
the issue with doing that is
you never told people you know so dc now
comes out what [ __ ]
seven years later give me a million
bucks but if if the fighters knew how
much those discretionary bonuses were
then in your contract you could
negotiate you know but that's why they
do that that's one of the reasons they
do it
it was undisclosed bonuses
yeah it's cool you have a million bucks
but imagine how much money they made
true
uh this is just
i think that yeah daniel cormier talked
about mma fighting and he just
made a comment about jones again uh man
you did some stuff to micro that never
let me settle because now i don't know i
could know through the fight that maybe
this dude is just better than me but
also know that if you're not doing the
things that are boosting you can really
work to that level that i'm working at
i can't let it go he's a cheater
interesting
all right
oh check this out yeah to be fair though
you asked my guy doing below the week of
the fight staying up to [ __ ]
six a.m you know
yeah so if you also got rest would he be
like he's able to compete at that level
and still
really not train
you know it's double
he did pop
yeah but also
not professional in all aspects so again
he's not getting the proper nutrition
proper training you are so you have an
advantage there now that's on him and
that's you know it's interesting yeah i
get what dc is saying
100 truly truly yeah you don't know
you're like yeah
maybe i am the greatest of all time and
he was on [ __ ] pds we don't but
it's too late now
yep
all right this one i
don't know what to think of it but tyson
fury was on his instagram saying that he
would the only way he get out of
retirement to fight joshua is if they
did it for free why for free for the
fans
why not make money off it tyson
that's how the fight happens i'll sign
the contract today he's only 33 too the
fight's got to be for free free to air
on television and all tickets go for
free nobody's to be made out of this
british historic fight if it happens
there's the terms i'm in the driving
seat take it or effing leave it the
balls in your your court guys either way
i don't give a damn makes no sense
well i yeah i mean i think for him too
he's like i don't have to do [ __ ] i'll
do it for free and you know joshua's not
gonna do it for free he's not tyson fury
although he makes so much money
but yeah tight move
and this is uh
charles oliveira and his bling jesus
christ
he definitely brought the brain to bling
to london
yeah
that's pretty cool
um oh this i thought was just funny
hilarious have you seen this video my
brother showed me this look how much
cocaine oscar's on
eyes dude
[Music]
i love when he passed it all
it's so trippy
the guy likes blow yeah who cares
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah whatever he's
old he's not fighting i'm fine as [ __ ]
probably tired he's up all night you
know doing the goddamn thing all right
so this is a few months old but i didn't
see it before i'll play it for you
last fight i was tired i was exhausted
i'm about to launch this nft that's
gonna change the fight game and i put in
30 all-nighters before that fight at
herpes before that fight two outbreaks
in the span of a week i'm here i'm
healthy let's go whatever it doesn't
matter
no doubt yeah it sounds like you've been
through a lot of herpes what's that two
outbreaks in a week
now and also the the commentator it
looks like joe rogan and bassroon had a
baby
he looks like a combo no it looks like
bassrutin rogan and jimmy smith yeah
they have a just a baby and that's this
guy and there he is there you go
i've been through a lot man we got ft i
haven't slept in 30 days i have herpes
less than a week god damn i know like
why are you dropping nft man it's a
herpe nfd
yeah pretty crazy comes and goes
we can keep it forever mm-hmm that
that's herpes
that sucks um yeah so this is before the
fight with uh javier fortuna this is
ryan garcia i guess he looked good too
man you look great i guess he lost his
150 000 watch at that time
and somehow javier fortuna found it and
gave it back to him to say what watch it
is uh no that's it
go what's the video there i'll show you
what did he just give him i don't know
this fight doesn't get
de la hoya just
blitzed he's all
oh my gosh
de la hoya classic yeah speaking of
watches we kind of talked this talked
about this off air but
drake bet like two something million he
won three here's thing kids listen
they're i love drake drake is my
favorite person on this earth not
including my kiddos he's right up there
but um
how long do you guys want to pretend
that he's actually putting
time and looking into the bets and that
this isn't all a promotion if you don't
think who i don't know who he's using
every is it steak
s-t-a-k-e
scouse scouser a scouser's probably at
stake
here's how this goes state goes hey
drake here's
10 million 20 million dollars
post that on who you've been bet on
these two these two are going to win
finally seriously make you look better
because there's the drake curse right
like whenever drake's gone for someone
or bet on someone they've lost so they
call it the drake curse kind of like the
kardashian curse right when they date
these nba players and then they just
[ __ ] eat [ __ ]
so for drake he's been under the curse
steak uh betting goes hey drake you're
the most funny famous guy on earth post
your bets we'll tell you to bet on right
and we'll make we'll reverse this
cursory you make money it's good pr it's
good for the fighters and then you know
he made what he bet
2.2
yeah that's what's going on here and so
again i'm not at the hustle i'm just
letting you guys peek behind the curtain
here okay and this curtain's deep okay
so you're peeking behind the curtain uh
drake i bet if he ran into
a molly meatball at uh in toronto run
through the six he would not stop and
would not recognize her i would be
willing to bet on draftkings only okay
not steak draftking's only here because
again i'm on the curtain too so i would
be willing to bet if draftkings had odds
that drake if he was running through the
six if drake was running through the
scousers and trying to find the fifth
beetle he couldn't do it if he gave him
a lineup of two people if it was patty
pimlet and one guy that kind of looks
like a beetle drake could not figure out
who the fighter is
that's the way the business goes
and so he won three point seven you go
i'll give you guys new rolexes
hey dude
hey man
you're worth billions right you have a
private jet
so you're gonna go all out and you've
won 3.7 which didn't win 3.7 it's all
fake right so they're paying a flat fee
and then he's not getting that money
that's cool though i don't want to vote
for everybody but so
3.7 let's say let's say in some crazy
world he actually won 3.7 you won 3.7
off their hard work and you're giving
forty thousand dollar gift now some
people he he could do nothing
he could don't you think it's cool he
could do nothing yeah i guess
or he actually won all this money and he
doesn't know who they are and someone
told him to parlay the bet on him and he
could really hook him up you know
like what's three point seven million to
drake
ah i'd be willing to bet from one of his
shows he's making uh probably
that and merch or some [ __ ] you know so
nothing to him dude
but good for them yeah still cool
it's like when the rock you know here's
another here's the curtain here i am
right this is me curtain open it's like
when the rock
gave his stuntman who's been with him
for
18 years when he gave him a f-150
and then did anybody go uh
actually sponsored by f-150 and that
costs rock
nothing because ford gave it to him
because that's part of his deal so he
gave it to his guy who's literally
breaking his back in ct to play whatever
the [ __ ] seventh jumanji and that guy
starts crying
you know it's a good gesture but figure
it out here's the curtain what's up rock
got that car for free and he gave him a
basic f-150
you could have done more rock is all i'm
saying you know what i'm saying i know
you're saying
you know rock also this is like not that
brand new news but logan paul i guess
they used to do videos together and do
do stuff because when logan was with
disney i guess they did a lot of stuff
with them
and then logan gets in trouble at the
japanese forest and then rock was like
privately that's my time
yeah probably can you delete all of our
pictures and he went through like his
representative instead of doing it like
yeah yeah pretty much jacked up pretty
shady yeah yeah but you know
pr move that's this curtain pr in
general you know if you're trying to
[ __ ] sell jumanji seven you don't be
associated with logan paul at that time
you know
especially overseas it's a bad luck yeah
he needs his fans would that be like me
like guys i'm gonna do a life-changing
thing
chin i'm gonna give you a can of rain
everyone's like
what aren't you sponsored by don't you
get free rain i'm like yeah
jen i'm gonna hook you up because i
appreciate all your hard work here's a
here's a can of nicotine from rogue
hey chin i can't tell you how much i
appreciate coming to work every day
here's a thick boy t-shirt
you know yeah same [ __ ] pretty much
same [ __ ] yeah he's just at a much
higher level you know
okay and i appreciate the work man i'm
gonna give you one free ticket to the
next one championship right you know
it's like didn't you just sign a deal
with him i did
butcher me in the front row but i'll
take it yep can you pay for my flight
absolutely not it's in singapore
all right so this is uh
reiner de ritter i'll pay for your
flight but you're flying spirited
19 hours
19 hours to singapore spared it can you
imagine dude
no yeah that would suck
what is this uh this is uh his name is
reiner der ritter from one championship
and he did this
i guess inverted triangle
i'll show you oh that's filthy
very rare you see this
did you pull the elbow over
oh wow it's tight tight
hold the arm doug oh damn we put him to
sleep
that guy just didn't know he was in it
nope
didn't know he's in it just too late
yeah
that's sick that's dope
that's a great highlight jen thanks dude
uh this is i don't know seriously but so
sean o'malley says he wants half of
sterling's pay-per-view points because
he believes all the fans are going to be
coming for his fight with john
that's funny yeah
to be fair yeah he's bigger but that's
not the way the ufc works it's also like
when jake paul talks about his biggest
pay-per-view numbers when he was on the
mike tyson guard
you don't think like ty said anything do
that and he'll jo he knows though he's
your crown bike yeah i mean mike had
some to do with it but everyone you know
so yeah sugarcon great headline though
yeah yeah he's right more people he's
more famous than sterling even though
he's you know the guy
all right um that's pretty much
recurrence that's it kids i give a
little preview of ufc 277 this saturday
there will be a fight companion only for
the main event
7 p.m pacific on thick boy youtube live
i will announce the lineup who will be
joining me sipping whiskey put in
nicotine having a grand old time that is
this saturday you'll see 277 fight
companion cal best fight companion uh
i'll have some news for you as far as
old school fight pain goes too
with mr joe rogan eddie bravo bronco
myself
but yeah this saturday is not that crew
the saturday is the cowbest fight uh
crew so um that's this saturday at 7 pm
live on thick boy youtube and uh i'm off
this week from toronto i'll be doing
spots around la pressing me at the laugh
factory improv this week i know about
the laugh factory on tuesday night um
but outside that the trash panda tour
continues in baltimore maryland never
been looking forward to it baltimore is
freaking august 4th through the 6th and
then uh
the next date is chicago august 26th one
night one show only 7 p.m show at the
den theater in chicago because august
27th is the tough mudder right outside
chicago
it's me versus the buttery bros
competition at the 10 a.m thick mudder
in chicago sign up right now tough
mudder promo code is team brendan and
you can sign up to run with me it is
limited capacity
so i'm telling you if you wait to like
the week of there's going to be no spots
because last time we had over 500 people
sign up it's too many people so they
can't put all of us in the same heat so
they break it up people get pissed
because you're not running with your
thick friend here and the thick crew
mark and the rest of the boys so they're
putting a capacity limit on it so you
can run with me so that is at 10 a.m uh
on the 27th in chicago go to tough
mudder right now and sign up for that
but uh tour wise august 26 that is a
friday and that's a one show only at the
den theater then appleton wisconsin
september 8th through the 10th ontario
just got announced ontario ontario
improv september 15th through the 17th
then i end september in boston i can't
wait for this laugh boss and never done
it decide to forgo the wilbur theater
because i love bots so much i want to
spend some time there get my work in man
i'm there thursday through saturday
boston is laughed boston but
baltimore europe next week august 4th
through the 6th
let's run it like the wire let's dance
like ray lewis at the super bowl
baltimore is next week august 4th to the
6th
that's it kids we have a food truck
dropping on wednesday with michael
chandler on the thick boy youtube the
green room uh green room diaries bit for
san diego drops on all social media
platforms uh tomorrow tuesday and the
second part will be released on thursday
that's it enjoy the fights i will see
you saturday for the live fight company
at 7 p.m pacific on thick boy youtube uh
any tickets you need thinkboy.com we
have think boy merch dropping soon too i
will announce that we have some dope ass
tie-dye stuff dropping and the white uh
shirt you see me wearing in the tank top
and the tee drops as well um stay posted
on it's coming up very soon all right
love you guys man i'll see you around
the city in la if you're here if not
baltimore i will see you next week and
be nice to each other be safe stay thick
love you i'm out